we've been looking at graphs this whole
topic right
and so that's why i'm just going to
quickly get back into my head
the three different kinds of graphs that
we've looked at in a very quick form
okay
but i'm going to do more than that i'm
going to tell you what these graphs what
they're really about and then i'll tell
you what the name of the process is
which is the heading
okay so for each of these i'm going to
give you an analogy
right a situation that will match up to
what the picture
is like okay so here's my first
picture my first picture
is about donuts okay donuts are simple
um but if you go to like if you get a pl
basically like i think it's extortion
right
the the schemes for prices of doughnuts
are ridiculous okay
there is a little bit of like oh if you
buy this many donuts
um it'll be a bit cheaper and so on but
essentially
it's like yeah they totally are absolute
money-making exercise i suppose that's
the point right
so if i buy zero donuts right i'll call
this my donut access
okay how much am i going to have to pay
what's the cost
so this is this is my cost access right
and the answer is if i buy no doughnuts
i'll pay nothing it costs zero okay
so if i buy those exactly okay now as i
buy more doughnuts
just if i if they're like say a dollar a
piece
you're getting something like this okay
yeah i know
who who am i kidding right if i if i got
a dollar don't i'd um
i'd buy the whole shop now there you go
basically
that's what's happening more donuts more
cost and this particular shape as it go
goes up in a straight line we call these
so there you go there was our first
variety
donuts was the first analogy the second
analogy is area
okay so what if i were to give you a
square okay so i don't have a square
shaped object here so i'm just going to
draw one
okay so if i have a square and in a
square all you need to know
for like its dimensions is you need one
number how long the side is
right like this because once you know
that how do you find out the area
if it was say you know that looks like
maybe five centimeters
from top to bottom it'd be five
times five you'd square it wouldn't you
okay so if i have
here like how long is the side so this
is my
side axis right and if i compare that to
the area
okay the area is going to be the side
and square
right so area equals side
squared right now there's two axes but
we usually label them
on these kinds of things we usually
label x and y
right so this would be y equals x
squared and we know what this is what
shape's that going to give us
a parabola very good okay so we're going
to have something like this
now you'll notice i've only drawn this
half right because
what would this side of the graph mean
it would mean
yeah the side length is like minus three
centimeters that kind of doesn't make
sense in this particular situation
okay so i'm just going to kind of put a
dotted line over here because you know a
parabola has two halves to it
but in this particular situation as with
this one
well what would this doesn't necessarily
make sense okay
well it depends on the situation
um no i'm just pretty there to show you
okay
yeah that's right the shape keeps on
going but for our situation which is
area
our analogy it doesn't have meaning over
here
okay okay third analogy i want you to
think back to
um when simon popper came along and he
gave us that that
performance down the mpc right and he
talked about
disease he talked about infection okay
now i know infections and like epidemics
and that kind of thing are complicated
things
but very simply the idea was that you
start with one person
who's sick and then he makes his
neighbor
sick right so one sick person turns into
two sick people right but then these two
guys
they make another two sick people so two
turns into four
right and then four is going to turn
into every one of them
is gonna make another person six so that
turns into eight and so on
right so this number keeps on doubling
and doubling
right so what would this look like
it's going to climb and it's going to be
yeah exponential
right and we've seen before that this
graph it sort of goes down
like that toward the axis okay so if we
had let's see
um this i suppose would be time
as time progresses how many sick people
do you have
and that number's going to increase
exponential until of course people start
dying
so they can't infect people anymore all
right so i gave you three analogies
right
donuts area and infection
i have a fourth analogy for you but this
time i'm going to do better than words
right i'm going to get out this is what
i had to go fetch
okay here's my fourth analogy
okay now my fourth analogy
is well actually i need to i need to
open this so would you please do the
honors
open it up for me because it's sealed i
haven't opened it yet you never know
i p i picked someone i picked someone
who's trustworthy did i make a mistake
okay all right thank you very much okay
now
as you what i'm gonna do with this right
is um first
i want us to know how many chocolates
there are in here now what do you guess
i'm guessing it's gonna be between 20
and maybe what's the maximum you think
you could fit in this box
maybe 50 40 they're about okay all right
let's let's count this up then okay so
i'm going to give
some to you know
watch and you can count those can you
count them up please
each one and then we'll add them up
how many do you have seven and turn
ten so how many is that twenty-six
jacob's closest there you go okay
so
at the moment at least we've got 26
chocolates okay
26 chocolates right now
here's my picture here's what i'm trying
to work out right if i have to
share this how many chocolates am i
going to get
let's think about that actually let's
think about what happens if
a single person got all of the
chocolates right
well there are 26 in total so not that
hard to work out they'll get 26 choco
that's right
um do it this way actually okay
one person 26 chocolates for that person
okay but let's suppose hey luke i think
that's a bit unfair i brought the
chocolates to class
after all right so let's split it
between you and me i'll be i'll be
reasonable okay right
so i'll get all the rappers you'll get
the [ __ ] so if if they're not
just one person getting them if there
are two people how many will we have
each
well 13. okay right now
i know it's uneven but you know roughly
i've distributed among
three people now this is a bit trickier
if i have three people
if i were to do it fairly because at the
moment it's not fair is it right
if i were to do it fairly how many
chocolates would each person get
there's 26 to share right how many would
they get
how would you work it out to make sure
don't be spending they would need to get
six and there'll be one left over will
they each get six
okay so let me work this out right if
i've got three people
and they each have six chocolates right
that's going to be
18 chocolates and then
how many there are there's more than one
spare leftover right
okay so they're actually not going to
get six are they sorry
that's okay that's that's the whole
point of working this out right
if they were each to get eight which
looks a little more close to what
they've actually got right
that's gonna be 24 so there'll be two
chocolates left over
what should we do with those two
chocolates
if i want to be fair between three but i
should slice them into thirds that's
exactly right and each person
would get two of the thirds okay so
we're gonna get eight so that's two and
two
what if we added one more person in the
mix
okay now hold on a second i'm gonna
pause right
i want you to think about what is this
what have we just made
what have we just made maybe if i put
some lines around him you'll be able to
see
aha yeah this is a table of values isn't
it i just sort of um
i fooled you with chocolate right except
usually we have x's and y's
but now what was what's this first row
about what did we start with
that's how many people right right
that's how many people
and then this is how many chocolates i
get right
so therefore these things correspond to
just like these things they correspond
to axes right
so i've got people on my horizontal axis
right so i'm working out how what
happens to the chocolate is i get more
and more people
so chocolate is my vertical axis this is
my chocolate axis if only
all the axes were chocolate okay so
i want you to think about well what
happens
right how far could we how far could you
go
forever what numbers oh okay now okay
so the the first question is how far can
you go
can you go on forever is there some
endpoint if not
or if so right here's my question to you
right um
this this linear graph it has an
equation like this
yep this parabolic graph has an equation
like what did we say
x squared good thank you guys this
exponential graph
it has an equation like
two it's it we swapped the power and the
base didn't we to the power of x
now our question to you is and this is
the last graph under our topic that's
why we featured today
number one what what's this going to
look like and number two
what what is this thing right now i'll
give you now the title
right so i didn't want to give it to
your phone because you would
misunderstand what we're doing here
this is called and this is what
mathematicians do
it's called modeling right not like
catwalk modeling
but we're trying to come up with a
mathematical model
of something that happens in real life
right now
in reality things might be slightly off
you know this graph here
it might have like you know wiggles and
bumps in it all that kind of thing
but we're trying to understand a
mathematical model that gives us
some understanding even if it's not
exactly perfect so
what's it going to look like what might
this
end up as i'll give you a few minutes to
draw a picture and then come up with a
conjecture okay